Vous me posez beaucoup de questions
sur les réseaux sociaux les Epicurieux
et sur YouTube avec le hashtag #DisJamy
et notamment sur le corps humain
et vous n'y êtes pas allés de main
morte. C'est parti !
Une question de Candy Neige Andre
Notre peau produit
naturellement une substance grasse
qu'on appelle le sébum.
Son rôle ? Constituer un film sur la peau
pour la protéger
des agressions extérieures.
Sauf qu'à certaines périodes de la vie,
il arrive que l'on en produit
un peu trop. À l'adolescence
par exemple, à cause d'une
surproduction d'hormones sexuelles.
Dans ce cas, les canaux par lesquels
arrivent le sébum peuvent se boucher.
Le problème, c'est que certaines bactéries
sont friandes de sébum
et se multiplient dans ces zones
d'embouteillage.
Le corps essaie alors de se défendre
contre cette invasion.
C'est à ce moment
que les boutons apparaissent.
Ils sont d'abord gonflés et rouges
parce que l'apport de sang
augmente dans la zone
pour lutter contre l'infection.
Puis, parfois, ils deviennent blancs
à cause du pus qui apparaît
lorsque les défenses immunitaires
attaquent les bactéries.
C'est le prix à payer,
en quelque sorte, pour faire peau neuve.
On ne rigole pas aux chatouilles
comme à une bonne blague.
Le rire des chatouilles est en fait
une réaction émotionnelle,
une sorte de mécanisme de défense
face au fameux guili-guilis.
D'abord, les chatouilles ne fonctionnent
que sur certaines parties du corps
les aisselles ou le cou notamment,
deux zones particulièrement vulnérables.
Car ici, pas de gros vaisseaux sanguins
qui réagissent plus intensément
à la moindre forme d'agression.
Le contexte est également important.
Essayez de chatouiller
un inconnu dans la rue,
vous verrez qu'il n'aura
pas envie de rire.
Et puis, il faut que les chatouilles
soient un jeu partagé pour qu'on
puisse en rire, un peu comme deux chatons
qui se battent pour de faux.
Enfin, il faut aussi un effet de surprise.
C'est le fait d'ignorer
où les doigts de l'autre vont se poser
qui provoquent cette réaction.
La preuve, c'est qu'on ne peut pas
se chatouiller soi-même. Regardez !
ça ne fait rire que vous.
Pour faire simple, construire un os, c'est
un peu comme construire une maison.
Il faut d'abord une armature.
Pour l'os, elle est fabriquée par des cellules
spécialisées à partir de protéines.
Puis, il faut des murs qui rendront
l'ensemble solide.
Ce sont le calcium et d'autres minéraux
qui, apportés par le sang,
vont venir se fixer sur l'armature.
Tant que la croissance continue,
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans,
grosso modo, les cellules construisent
de l'armature et les os grandissent.
Mais il ne faut pas croire que nos os
se figent une fois la croissance terminée.
Les os sont vivants
et sont sans cesse renouvelés.
On estime qu'au cours d'une vie,
le squelette est entièrement renouvelé
quatre fois.
Dernière chose Sandra, plus on bouge, plus
on rend nos os solides.
Donc, plutôt que de regarder le sport
à la télévision,
mieux vaut le pratiquer en chair et en os.
Jonatan Féau aimerait savoir
De l'argot Jonathan. A partir du XIXe siècle.
Le mot boule devient un terme familier
pour désigner la tête.
Logique, l'homme a plutôt une tête ronde.
Pour le coup, on ne peut pas dire que nos
aïeux se soient trop creuser
la tête. De la même façon,
on parle aussi
de coups de boule
pour désigner un coup porté avec le crâne.
Et puis, le mot boule évoque également
le globe terrestre. Et oui!
Quand on perd la boule,
on a de bonnes raisons d'être déboussolé
et de perdre un peu le nord.
Aux États-Unis, on a préféré les billes
aux boules avec l'expression
"To lose your marbles".
Perdre ses billes,
qui veut dire perdre la tête. Les boules !
Des chercheuses britanniques
en psychologie se sont aussi posées
la question et pour y répondre, elles
ont observé de près des enfants chez qui
le phénomène est fréquent quand ils sont
en train de réaliser certaines tâches.
Et là, surprise, contrairement à ce
qu'on imagine, ce ne sont pas les tâches
qui demandent le plus de précision,
qui entraînent le plus de sorties longues.
Ce sont celles qui impliquent
une forme de communication.
Quand un enfant, par exemple,
s'amuse à faire les gestes inverses
de son camarade.
Cette observation
validerait d'ailleurs la théorie
selon laquelle le langage a évolué
à partir de gestes.
En résumé, lorsqu'il
s'agit de communiquer,
les mains et la langue sont liées.
Et quand on se concentre
pour bouger les premières,
la seconde se automatiquement.
C'est peut-être pour cette raison
que je bouge les mains quand je parle
et j'ai du mal à tenir ma langue.
Question de Hugo
L'être humain et bien d'autres animaux
sécrètent des larmes
pour protéger leurs yeux.
Mais nous sommes les seuls, par contre,
à pleurer lorsqu'on se fait mal
ou en cas d'émotions très fortes.
Des scientifiques ont essayé
de comprendre, mais ils n'ont pas réussi
à décrypter tous les mécanismes
qui entrent en jeu dans cette histoire.
Une des hypothèses est que les pleurs
servent à attirer l'attention.
Les bébés, par exemple, pleurent
pour signaler une douleur ou une envie.
Il s'agit donc d'un mode de communication.
Pour les adultes,
c'est peut être la même chose
une façon de communiquer,
de se soulager de quelque chose
que l'on a du mal à verbaliser.
Sacha de Marseille
veut savoir,
c'est à cause d'une substance
contenue dans le sang, la bilirubine.
Il s'agit en fait d'un déchet qui provient
de la destruction des globules rouges
une fois qu'ils sont usés
et qu'ils ne servent plus.
Quand le sang passe dans le foie
pour y être débarrassé de ses impuretés,
la bilirubine est retenue
et se retrouve dans la bile.
Elle est ensuite évacuée via les urines,
comme elle contient un pigment jaune.
Elle colore les urines en jaune.
Plus vous buvez d'eau,
plus la couleur est diluée.
En revanche, si vous êtes déshydraté,
les urines sont d'un jaune très soutenu.
Pour l'anecdote, les participants
au vernissage d'une exposition d’Yves Klein
en 1958 eurent la mauvaise surprise
de voir leurs urines devenir bleu.
Fan de cette couleur,
le peintre avait en effet ajouté
un peu de bleu de méthylène au cocktail
servi pendant la soirée.
Autant vous dire qu'ils étaient tous
un peu verts.
Retrouvez Cjamy du lundi au vendredi
à 16h55 sur France 5
ou dès maintenant sur France.tv.
Le lien est sous cette vidéo
et surtout, n'hésitez pas à vous abonner
et activez la cloche. Faites le savoir.